- If you have a dream, if you have this crazy
idea, you must believe in it even if no one
else does.
When you talk to people who have found the
work they were born to do, they are so excited
about it.
You can tell that they have found something
that is really unique.
I've never really been interested in living
a balanced life.
I think balanced people don't change the world.
I didn't want to get old, and be like, "Oh
like 10 years ago, I had this idea "to do
something but I never did anything about it."
We tend to focus on all of the fun things,
and the fun things are great but not everybody
wants to pay you to do those fun things.
I'm a big fan of defining our aspirations,
and then crafting our life around them essentially.
I actually don't think you need a niche.
I don't believe that you have to have something
super specific.
You have to connect with like-minded people.
You have to surround yourself with people
who aren't necessarily doing the same things
that you're doing but they have the same attitudes
or the same mindset at least.
She says, "People are always telling you "to
think outside the box."
She says, "My advice is to get in the box."
But because life is short, why not try to
work toward something that is not just okay
but is amazing?
I'm a writer, traveler, and entrepreneur.
I'm best known for going to every country
in the world, all 193, and for writing The
Art of Non-conformity blog and books.
My new book is called Born for This.
It's all about how to find the work you were
meant to do.
I'm Chris Guillebeau, and here are my top
10 rules for success.
If you have a dream, if you have this crazy
idea, you must believe in it even if no one
else does.
So when I had the idea to go to every country
in the world, that's what it felt like.
It felt like this crazy idea.
It was like, "This just sounds totally ridiculous
and absurd," but I couldn't stop thinking
about it, and I realized that if I didn't
pursue it, I would always regret it, and that
knowledge, that fear of regret drove to say
yes, and I talk to lots of other people who
use very similar language.
There is a guy from Portland Maine whose crazy
idea was to walk across America, and he wasn't
even sure like, "How does that work?
"How much time does it take?
"Has anyone done this before?"
It was this crazy idea that wouldn't leave
him alone, and so one morning, he left his
home in Maine, and he started walking, and
7 1/2 months later, he arrived in San Francisco,
and I talked to him throughout the whole journey.
I talked to him in the beginning, and in the
middle, in the end, and I asked him, "What
were the challenges like?"
And, "How did it go?"
And he said, he said something that stayed
with me for the rest of my journey.
He said, "You know, there are lots of external
challenges.
"It was hard on the body to get used to walking
that much.
"Lots of things went wrong.
"There were some emotional challenges as well."
He just had a breakup, and he was processing
all of this.
He said, "But what I realized about two weeks
in, "once I stopped complaining "and rumbling
about the whole thing," he said, "I realized
that my task was pretty simple.
"All I had to do was walk essentially, "and
if I did nothing else, "if I got up every
morning, "and I made a little bit of progress,
"then eventually I would reach the goal, "eventually
I would arrive in San Francisco, "and achieve
that goal, reach that destination," and it
sounded really simple but it's stayed with
me for the final two years of my quest because
that's how I felt it was for me too.
All I had to do was get to 193 countries,
and I had my list of countries, and I was
making progress, and if I got stuck somewhere,
eventually I'd have to overcome that challenge
but I could go and do some others first, and
I liked the logical, analytical progress of
it.
It's something that related to me so just
keep going, you have to believe in your dream
even if no one else does.
I think a lot of people, when I talk to people
about this book, they were worried about mistakes
they had made, and they were worried about
like, "You know, I had this opportunity and
I let it go," or, "I should have done this,
"and I ended up doing something different."
I really learned that you can recover from
most mistakes like most of us have made mistakes.
We have done different things, and that's
normal so there are a lot of different paths.
I don't think there is just necessarily one
path for everyone.
There is whole poem about the road not taken
or the road less traveled, and I took this
one and it made all the difference but we
don't really know the other story, right?
We don't know what happened like what if you'd
actually gone back and taken the other one?
Maybe it would have been great too.
Maybe it would have been better.
So I do think there is more than one path
but I also think when you talk to people who
have found the work they were born to do,
they are so excited about it.
You can tell that they have found something
that is really unique and really special.
So even though there is more than one path,
I think it's important to work toward whatever
this special thing is, work toward this combination
of factors to where we're really happy, and
we have all the money that we need, and we're
doing something that we're really good at.
I think that's the goal, right?
So it's not like this one elusive thing but
if you look at really successful people, if
you look at Beyonce, Beyonce probably could
have done a bunch of different things but
isn't it so good that she's doing what she's
doing?
Or anyone that you do admire.
You look at them and you're like, "They have
really found their thing."
I've never really been interested in living
a balanced life.
I think balanced people don't change the world
first of all.
I think balanced people don't really follow
a dream.
It doesn't mean that you don't have responsibilities
like just go to all the previous question,
"How can you have a family?"
Sure, you can have a family.
I feel like balance is like a made-up word.
It's like invented by corporations to make
their employees think that they're happy.
It's like you got this balance.
You could work at Microsoft or something here
in Seattle.
- [Chase] There is like 10 Microsoft people
in the audience in here.
- That's right.
- No disrespect to Microsoft.
Let's pick another.
Microsoft is a great company.
- [Chase] One in every five people in Seattle
works at Microsoft.
- That's right.
And it's like you got this thing, and maybe
you love your job, and if you love your job,
that's great but I hear from a lot of dissatisfied
people at some of these big companies, and
they write in, they're like, "I'm reading
your blog "from my cubicle, and like I had
this good job, "and I've got my health insurance,
I've got free yoga "every Thursday but I'm
not really--"
- Fulfilled.
- Right, "I'm not really fulfilled."
So for me, I guess I'm much more interested
in that word fulfilled.
How can you live a fulfilled life?
You can live a fulfilled life, and still pay
your bills.
Lots of creative people do it.
Lots of unconventional people do it.
I would say, if anything, it's actually much
more common now than it used to be.
When I first started working online 15 years
ago, I didn't know a lot of other people who
were doing that.
My friends thought I was selling drugs or
something.
- [Chase] Well, you were.
- I was but.
Or like online gambling or whatever.
My parents have no idea how the internet works
and stuff but now it's much more common so
I don't really like the word balance myself.
- So what we'd like to do is we want to replace
the word, like living a balanced life is not
the goal, the goal is living a fulfilled life.
- I started traveling.
I had been to a bunch of countries.
I really liked it.
I lived in West Africa for four years, and
started trying to figure out, "Okay, how many
countries have I been to?
"How many countries in the world are there?"
Once I had this information, it was very difficult
to do anything else, right?
Because once I had this information, I was
like, "Oh I've been to like 50 countries.
"There's 193 countries.
"It was 192.
"I would like to visit 100 countries some
time in my life."
I set that goal first.
- But you just said, you say, "I would like
to "'cause I would like to do a lot of things--"
- No no, I want to.
I feel drawn to it.
I feel like this is a goal attached to myself,
and at the time, it wasn't public.
It was just like a private thing.
This is before I was blogging.
And then as I started getting closer to that
goal of 100 countries, that's when I thought,
"What's next?"
Because if you're only going to half the countries,
then you're missing a lot of challenges, and
you could just go to easy places.
And so I had this information, I was like,
"Could I really go to every country?"
I don't know if I could or not.
This is a huge thing.
It's going to cost a lot, not just in terms
of money but also in terms of time and sacrifice
and logistics.
Things could go wrong, fear.
But really what it came down to for me was
not the fear of something going wrong along
the way, once I actually started thinking
about this, I was like, "Maybe I could actually
do this in seven to eight years if I really
worked at it.
Then what I was afraid of was not doing it.
I was afraid of having this idea, and then
just passing on it, and just continuing to
travel a little bit.
I'm that guy who travels once in a while but
what's that?
And then I didn't want to get old, and be
like, "Oh 10 years ago, I had this idea "to
do something but I never did anything about
it."
That's what drove me.
- The fear of being ordinary or if not--
- The fear of regret, of not following up
on a dream that I had, that I knew, I didn't
know if I could succeed, I thought it might
fail but I figured if I failed, I could deal
with that but not if I just didn't do it.
- Right.
- [Chris] That's what drove it.
- For those people who've heard your story,
and want to live a non-conformist traveling
lifestyle as well, could you recommend a business
model we start out with?
We tried info products, we tried eBay.
What do you recommend?
- Dude, the most important thing I recommend
regardless of what the specific business model
is is to really focus on what I call the convergence
between what you want to do, and what you're
passionate about, and what other people are
also passionate about, and what other people
are actually willing to exchange money for
because those things can be different sometimes.
I think often when we focus on like vocation
independence and doing what you want stuff,
and we tend to focus all of the fun things,
and the fun things are great but not everybody
wants to pay you to do those fun things so
you have to find a link between what you can
do that's really helpful, where your skills
are, how your passions can align with other
people, and that took me quite a while to
figure it out but if you really focus on that
from the beginning, then I think that helps
regardless of the specific business model.
Now in terms of the business model, right
now I'm in the information publishing business.
I really do love it.
I think it's great but there's other things
you can do as well so it just depends on what
you're into and what kind of business you
want to pursue I think.
- We all have these great ideas, right?
And at the same time, we have responsibilities
and mortgages and whatever so I guess I'm
just wondering what your advice is to people
who want to go out and pursue certain things
but there are also certain limitations I guess
that we have to exist within.
I guess we don't but you know, I can't walk
away from my condo tomorrow and walk across
the country.
It probably wouldn't work out well for me
but yeah, what's your advice?
- That's a great question but do you want
to walk across the country?
Is that your aspiration?
So I'm a big fan of defining our aspirations,
and then crafting our life around them essentially,
and so the quest to visit every country in
the world for example, I was thinking about
this the other day.
People ask how much it cost, right?
And the first 100 countries cost about $30,000.
So 30,000 at least I would argue, is not a
huge amount of money for going to 100 countries,
and all the life experience that I got through
that, and also I didn't have to pay it all
right away.
You pay as you go essentially and something
like that so you know, these limitations as
you said, maybe let's not call them limitations,
they're responsibilities especially people
with families.
You don't just leave your family, and walk
across the country but again, there are ways
to cultivate the value of adventure.
That's why I like the story of Sasha and what
she did at home.
There is a woman in Omaha who's knitting 10,000
hats, and her passion, the thing that she
really loved was always knitting, and one
Christmas time or holiday time, she made 100
hats for her friends and family, and she was
like, "That's really fun.
"I want to do 1,000," but 1,000 is not a big
enough challenge so she took on this goal
of 10,000 hats, and there is a charity component
to it.
You can connect with her on her website, and
eventually get a hat.
I don't know.
Responsibilities and things are real but if
something matters to us, I guess I'm also
a believer in figuring out how to do that,
right?
Like we do have to trade off things, we do
have to sacrifice, and especially for all
of us who have so many opportunities available
to us, it's a matter of prioritization, it's
a matter of.
I can probably do anything I want but I can't
do everything, right?
So if this thing really does matter to me,
whether it's walking across the country or
whatever it is in your case, then it's something
that you have to plan for and build for, and
for me, it was worth it to do that.
- When you're starting a blog or trying to
build an audience, how important is it to
have a niche, and what can you do if you have
multiple interests?
- You find a way to meld the different interests,
you find a way, so I'm going to paraphrase
a little bit, to put them together, and the
word that I like to use is not niche or niche,
I like to use the word theme so I actually
don't think you need a niche.
I don't believe that you have to have something
super specific.
I know that there are some people who say
that, and maybe that's been true for them.
That's great.
In my case, it certainly wasn't the way that
I chose to do it, and partly that was because
I was worried I would get bored if it was
something too specific.
I had started a lot of projects in the past
where I was really motivated and excited for
a while but then it dropped off, and with
this one, when I started writing the blog,
it was something that I really liked the medium,
and I wanted to be able to keep doing it for
a long period of time so I didn't choose a
niche but I did, as Dave referred to, I did
meld the interests together, and I chose a
theme, and I said, "What do all these things
have in common?"
It's more of a world view, non-conformity
than it is anything super specific.
You have to connect with like-minded people.
You have to surround yourself with people
who aren't necessarily doing the same things
that you're doing but they have the same attitudes
or the same mindset at least.
So that's another thing that has been transformative
because now when I meet readers or I come
to do things like this, I find it, I come
in this weird business of inspiration, right?
And people are like, "Oh so inspiring," but
it's totally true that I legitimately drive
a great deal of my inspiration from the feedback
and interaction as you were saying with Twitter
so online and offline.
Online is great.
Relationships can be forged online, and you
actually meet that person, and you feel like
you know them already and stuff.
When I do stuff like this, part of the reason
we do the World Domination Summit is to bring
together people who are like-minded especially
if they come from small towns or something,
and I hear this a lot of like, "I live in
this place "where it's not like Seattle or
Portland or whatever.
"There is just not a lot of people "who think
like I do," or, "My ideas aren't accepted,"
or, "My family doesn't understand why I want
to be an artist "or why I want to travel."
And it's just like, "Why don't you just go
on vacation?
"Why don't you "go and see the world?"
So bringing people together, and then just
myself, by being in that, it's helped so,
so much.
I guess the general principle is I am pro-goal,
right?
I am pro-parameters.
There is this good story in the book about
a woman named Elise Blaha Cripe who is a serial
crafter, and she makes all this stuff, and
she shares it with the world, and she's incredibly
prolific, and her whole advice is she says,
"People are always telling you to think outside
the box."
She says, "My advice is to get in the box
basically, "and make yourself a box," like
make yourself these parameters, these goals,
whatever.
Again, it's not something that's being imposed
on you.
That's really the clear point.
It's not like someone is saying, "Here is
your goal, "and here is what you should do,"
it's you, it's the things that you select
for yourself but I believe there is so much
possibility in those parameters or in those
constraints as we talked about so whether
it's like, "My goal is to climb Mount Everest,"
or maybe the 10 mountains or something, and
in stages are also good so stages are milestones,
the levels in Mario Brothers.
For me, it was like 50 countries, 100 countries,
then it was like every continent.
Once I finished all of Africa, that was a
big thing.
So I do think it's important to celebrate
small wins along the way.
Everybody who is successful, and by successful,
I mean like absolutely fulfilled in their
career, passionate about it, and feeling like
they're doing something that they're supposed
to do, they have these three characteristics,
and first of all, they have joy, they're happy
in their work, they enjoy what they do most
of the time, they're not doing a soul-sucking
job.
If they have a job, it's a great job, or if
it's something that they built for themselves,
they really enjoy it.
And the second quality is money is because
there's lots of things you can do that you
enjoy but if you don't get paid for them,
then it's a hobby, which is great, it's good
to have a hobby but if you're talking about
a career, it has to be financially sustainable.
So joy, money, and then the third factor is
flow, which is really doing something that
you're good at, really doing something where
when you do it, you're immersed in it, and
the hours just pass by, and it's also really
easy for you 'cause it's something that you're
good at, and other people are like, "Wow,
she's really good at that.
"It takes me a lot longer to do that," or,
"I'm not good at it," but so I think what
we're looking for is this combination of all
three factors.
We want something that brings joy, we want
something that is financially sustainable,
we want something that brings flow, and I
don't think people will be happy unless they
have all three of these factors.
I think you can be okay, right?
There is lots of people who do jobs they don't
love, and that's fine, they get a paycheck,
and maybe they're satisfied in other areas
of their life but because life is short, why
not try to work toward something that is not
just okay but is amazing, right?
Isn't that the goal?
- So those are the top 10 rules but since
we have you here live, I'd love to hear a
bonus 11th rule from you.
- Okay.
All right, no pressure.
Bonus 11th rule is if something isn't working,
I think you should stop doing it.
I think you should quit.
And this runs contrary to a lot of things
that you've been told.
In your business education, through case studies,
et cetera, you've probably been told that
winners never quit, and what I saw through
my research, looking at lots of successful
people who've done a lot of amazing things,
winners actually aren't afraid to quit, winners
quit all the time, and so I think it's not
persistence that's the predictor of success,
it's flexibility and adaptation.
Being willing to go down a path and say, "Actually
that's not the right path for me.
"I'm going to go back and then take the other
path "or I'm going to create an all-new path."
So winners never quit maybe but winners actually
give up all the time.
- And how do you know, and here is the magic
question, how do you know when to quit and
when to keep going 'cause this is still your
dream and this is really hard?
- Absolutely.
Here is the magic answer.
You ask yourself two questions.
Is it working?
Do I still believe in it?
So if it's not working but you still believe
in it, then you have to change what you're
doing, you have to adapt because it's not
working.
You have to recognize the reality but if you
still believe in your dreams, you have to
change it.
If it's not working, you don't believe in
it, then you stop and you quit.
I would also say if it's actually working
okay but you no longer believe in it, you
have to make a change there too 'cause ultimately
you're not going to be fulfilled doing something
you don't care about.
- And what would you tell people who don't
know what they believe in yet?
I guess read the book.
- Oh sure.
- There is a lot of anxiety around finding
the perfect job for me, the perfect business.
How do I go about finding something to actually
believe in?
- Yeah, here are some reassurance.
Most people actually have no idea what it
is.
Most people do not know their life purpose
when they're 20 or even 30 or older.
What most successful people do is they go
down a lot of different paths.
They do not follow a linear path.
They aren't actually driven from a young age
to be this profession or whatever, they experiment,
they aren't afraid to go back as I said but
over time, they refine, over time, they discover
that but if you don't experiment, you won't
discover it.
- I love it.
So thank you, guys, so much for watching.
- Hey, thanks a lot, Jay Rise.
I heard you nominated me to be on the program.
I really appreciate that, man.
Thank you.
- I'd love to know which of the top 10 rules,
or 11 rules I guess here, you guys like the
most.
Leave it in the comments below, and I'll join
in the discussion.
Now usually I throw it over to you guys for
your suggestions on who to profile next but
since I have Chris here with me, if you had
to pick a few people for who do want to see
a profile of, who would you pick?
- Right, right.
Obviously it's an amazing show so I got to
think of amazing people.
First person I thought of is my good friend
Jonathan Fields.
He lives in New York City.
He's done a lot of different things.
He's probably most known for the Good Life
project now.
Fantastic video series.
Michelle Poler, also in New York although
she's originally from Venezuela.
She did 100 Days of Fear project where every
day, she made a different video all about
fears she was overcoming.
Really, really good stuff.
And then the third person I'm thinking of
is Barbara Sher, and Barbara Sher is a little
bit older.
She's been writing books for at least 30,
40 years.
A lot of people who are new get credit for
this lifestyle design movement but she's actually
been doing it for a very, very long time.
She wrote a book called Wishcraft like W-I-S-H.
Wishcraft, that influenced me a lot.
- So thank you, guys, so much for watching.
Make sure you pick up a copy of Born for This.
Continue to believe, and we'll see you soon.
- I like a quote by Seth Godin.
He said, "Effort can be its own reward if
you let it."
So we're talking about motivations.
I think it's critical to be motivated by doing
the work itself, that the work itself is enjoyable,
maybe not each aspect of it, right?
But it has to be because as you said, you
can tell, you can see drafts and iteration,
you can see like a person's gone through something,
and I guess for me, once I was like, and once
I actually found a little bit of process,
I said, "Okay, I'm going to write this blog
post, "and then write books and things."
I was like, "This is what I want to do."
It's great.
It's wonderful that people care about it now.
it's great that so many people do but I'm
pretty sure I would do it anyway, and I said
in the beginning, I was like, "I just want
to put this out for those who care," so for
me, I'm very motivated by, we talked about
deliverables earlier.
Every day, I'm trying to write 1,000 words.
This is an actionable habit--
- Yeah, I want to get into that.
We made some notes about this.
What are these tactics?
- Tactics.
For me, I said I'd write 1,000 words a day,
and I'm always traveling and doing lots of
different stuff.
My goal is every day, I'm going to write 1,000
words.
A lot of it is not going to be good, some
of those are not going to be usable but that's
all right.
I'm just trying to create.
- [Chase] Every day?
Seven days?
- The way I think of it is like exercise.
If I miss a day or something, it's okay.
If I miss a couple days, I start feeling it.
So like five to six days a week basically.
- That's amazing.
Anybody out there in the audience--
- [Chris] It's not that hard.
It's amazing but let's pull that back 'cause
I don't think it's that hard.
- Right 'cause you're just sitting down and
doing the work.
Chuck Close, a famous artist, said, "If I
only painted or if I only went to work "when
I was inspired, I wouldn't have done very
much work."
There is a process of getting up every morning,
and sitting down and writing.
- Right, inspiration is like sitting down
to do it, you know?
Jack London, it's like inspiration doesn't
find you, you find it with a club or something.
You got to go after that inspiration, you
know?
- I love that.
I love that.
- So 1,000 words.
- 1,000 words.
These are tactics that a writer, that if you
want to write, you should do every day.
Get up and write 1,000 words.
- Focus on outcomes and deliverables, not
focus on time schedule.
What I mean by that is I often see advice
that's like, "Okay, you're going to set a
timer or something, "and you're going to work
on this project "from like eight o'clock to
8:50," or something like that, and that works
for some people and that's great but for me,
I'm like always in different timezones, lots
of stuff is happening so I'm only focused
on what the actual product is.
So a product is like okay, blog post, manuscript,
or something, interview, email, or something
so I'm always focused on shipping.
- [Chase] There is an objective, shipping
pieces of it.
- Shipping.
Shipping, deliverables, outcomes, and just
like that quote, "Effort can be its own reward,"
I find that enjoyable.
I find the process of sending something out,
or pressing the publish button or whatever,
I find that enjoyable, and so that's the reward
that I'm working for.
I'm not looking for the reward of like the
viral blog post, I'm not looking for the reward
of like lots of people buying something or
whatever.
That's great but those are by-products.
So I'm looking for the reward of getting it
out.
- So the reward is in the act, and the creative
act itself, and if the reward is not in the
creative act itself, then you're probably
doing the wrong thing.
- Then it's not sustainable, I would say.
It's either not sustainable or it's not good,
and the quality is not there, I would say.
One thing I believe is it's really important
to define your own success.
It's really important to decide for yourself
what success looks like as opposed to letting
someone else imposed their definition of success
upon you.
So whenever you begin a big project, if you're
doing something on your own, if you're starting
a business or a blog or going back to school
or even if it's an exercise program, whatever
it is, you should have your own definition
of success.
I think maybe if we go back to somebody who's
in that beginning part of their career, I
think the wrong advice to them would be, say,
just pick one of those things, and that's
what everybody says all the time.
They're always like, "Oh you have to focus.
"You have to just pick your niche or your
niche.
"You got to do that," and how are you really
going to find that combination of factors
of joy, money, and flow without expanding
your options, without trying a lot of different
stuff.
So you did that, you did that in your career.
I did that, and I think in the beginning part
of really trying to figure out what am I good
at, and also not just what am I good at but
what is going to be rewarded in the marketplace,
I said yes to a lot of different things, and
so I always encourage people when you're starting
out, expand your options.
Do everything that you can to have a lot of
different experiences, and then as you become
more successful, as you have more experience,
then you limit the options, then you start
being more selective, then you start being
like okay, I am going to apply that litmus
test more often.
I am going to say okay, I've got all these
different things I could do.
What is most aligned?
Where can I have the most convergence?
What am I really like getting close to?
How am I going to have the biggest impact
in the world?
But I don't think you can necessarily do that
when you're just getting started because you
don't know.